on voyait dans ces pensionnats comment
ça s'est passé le début de cette
politique coloniale était de venir en
territoire et prendre les enfants sans
le consentement des parents et ils
arrachent et de leur territoire pour les
amis dans d'autres régions dans deux
provinces très très loin l'objectif est
de tuer l'envié dans un faux joint
justement 182 tombes anonymes ont été
découvertes sur le site d'un ancien à
pensionnat à cranbrook en colombie
britannique
c'est la troisième découverte de ce type
en un mois on parle ici de génocide de
politique génocidaire ça va au delà de
la culture mais plutôt un crime contre
l'humanité observe une nation
[Musique]
la bataille parlementaire se poursuit
contre l'avis du gouvernement
l'assemblée nationale vote contre le
recours au passage et terre pour les
patients non urgents ou les visiteurs
dans les établissements de santé et
maisons de retraite
sur le millier d'amendements déposés sur
ce projet de loi quelques centaines
seulement été examinée elle des
manifestants anti pas sanitaires se sont
rassemblés devant le sénat conseil de
défense exceptionnel réuni ce matin par
emmanuel macron dédié l affaire et gaz
us le chef de l'état cible potentielle
du maroc via ce logiciel israéliens
veulent suivre au plus près ce dossier
rabat rejette ces accusations et attaque
en diffamation les deux organisations
qu'ils accusent d'espionnage aînés sony
à la télévision israélienne d'avoir
intégré le chef de l'état sur cette
fameuse liste
une enquête a été ouverte par le parquet
de paris
un accord enfin on le projet nord stream
de berlin et washington se sont entendus
sur ce fameux gazoduc qui doit relier la
russie à l'allemagne via la mer baltique
un revirement après des années de
blocage de la part des états unis
les deux pays menacent moscou de
sanctions en cas de dérapage dans
l'utilisation du projet la pologne et
l'ukraine voit rouge de leur côté
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous bienvenue à
vous si vous nous rejoignez sur rt
france l'assemblée nationale sous
tension les débats depuis hier sont très
tendues entre parlementaires autour du
projet de loi concernant l'extension du
pass elle sanitaire dans la rue les
rassemblements se poursuivent de
nombreux gilet jaune manifestent devant
le sénat où doit arriver et le texte
demain on y retrouve tout de suite notre
reporter 4 ça pique nique katia bonsoir
vous suivez ce rassemblement quelle est
l'ambiance sur place
écoutez l'ambiance est festive calme
avec de la musique des prises de parole
alors calme bien sûr mais ici les
manifestants sont déterminés à afficher
leur opposition totale à ce pas
sanitaire qui brident selon eux les
libertés individuelles
alors parlons des débats qui ont lieu en
ce moment à l'assemblée nationale il
reste de très nombreux amendements à
examiner en milieu d'après midi leur
reste encore sept cents le gouvernement
est pressé il insiste pour que
l'extension du pass sanitaires soient
validées ce week end
mais les députés d'opposition sont
mécontents car assure un sujet
d'importance comme celui ci veulent
pouvoir débattre et même une députée
centriste a ni un chapelier du groupe
agir qui pourtant alliés de la majorité
bien à la demande et une écoute réelle
christophe castaner contre quant à lui
pour sa part s'est dit d'accord pour le
débat parlementaire mais ne vaut pas non
plus qu'il freine je le cite
paris n'ose trucks systématique la
nécessité d'aller vite dans notre combat
contre la copie de fin de citation la
séance pourrait s'éterniser dans la nuit
ou reprendre demain on sait donc pas
encore si le texte ira au sénat demain
et concernant la colère des députés face
à aux débats parlementaires en ce moment
je propose à d'écouter jean luc
mélenchon chef de file de la france
insoumise la pression qui s'exerce sur
nous c'est nous dire bon durera jusqu'à
5 heures du matin bon bah on ira jusqu'à
5 heures du matin et 6 et 6 heures et
bas ce sera six heures mais je pense que
ce que ça discrédite surtout c'est ceux
qui prennent les décisions pareilles moi
j'ai déjà si j'ai ici deux fois de suite
jusqu'à 6 heures du matin vous souvenez
peut-être d'une force incroyable comment
voulez-vous cas comment voulez vous qu'à
5 heures ou à 6 heures on sache
lucidement où on en est à propos de
l'article machinchose sous-amendement
2037 enfin bon ce sont des conditions
déplorables qui discrédite le parlement
mais la responsabilité acquis à ceux qui
ont organisé toute cette histoire
hier générale or rassemblement national
et or députés les plus à gauche les
parlementaires sont pour l'obligation
vaccinale est tendue pour tous les
soignants les sapeurs pompiers également
les professionnels travaillant avec les
personnes âgées
il ya assez peu de changement malgré
tous ces amendements à extrêmement
nombreux il ya peu de changement du
texte et initiale le passé ni terre pour
les voyages internationaux seront exigés
qu'aux personnes de plus de 12 ans voilà
le premier changement un second pour les
12 17 ans il sera exigé à partir de la
fin septembre et non de la fin août
comme c'était marqué dans le texte
initial
autre changement pour les hôpitaux et
les ehpad et bien les visiteurs et les
patients seront dispensés de passes
sanitaire contre l'avis du gouvernement
donc des députés qui trouve le texte
incohérent qui trouvent qu'il est un qui
prive un certain de liberté liberté
individuelle qui sont réclamés c'était
aussi l'avis des manifestants ici je
vous prends plus de les écouter
normalement ils sont tous élus pour
censés nous représenter
mais j'ai l'impression que toutes les 10
hier et les décisions qui sont prises à
l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat vont
dans le sens des gouvernants mais pas
dans le sens de la population donc on
est là pour leur rappeler aussi que il
ya une grande majorité aussi de la
population qui n'est pas d'accord avec
ces lois liberticides qui sont votées
tout simplement donc nous je tiens à
rappeler qu'on est pas on n'est pas
contre le vaccin on est contre
l'obligation pour les gens de se
vacciner c'est que ce n'est pas la même
chose celui qui a envie de le faire et
qui estime que c'est bien pour lui mais
qu'il le fasse mais celui qui veut pas
on le laisse tranquille et on n'a pas
besoin de l'empêcher de le priver de tas
de liberté de sa vie sociale est encore
plus alors là de son travail
ce que je n'arrive pas à comprendre nous
nous sommes pour le droit en france
aujourd'hui pour le droit le pass
sanitaire c'est absolument interdits de
même que la vaccination obligatoire
ce sont des choses qui sont interdites
et donc selon le débat actuellement qui
est à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
c'est de prendre des lois qui modifie
les lois existantes pour imposer
justement quelque chose qui actuellement
interdit par exemple les discriminations
le code pénal interdit les
discriminations en fonction de l'état de
santé
et bien c'est de ça qu'il s'agit on va
maintenant instaurer un système où l'on
pourra diviser les français entre les
vacciner les longs jacques 6 mai des
manifestants ici qui ne sont pas venus
devant l'assemblée nationale parce que
comme vous avez entendu estime que ça ne
sert plus vraiment à rien donc ils sont
devant le sénat pour essayer de faire
pression pour les sénateurs car le texte
va arriver prochainement demain ou après
demain au sénat
ici disent qu'ils ne sont pas contre les
vaccins mais contre la privation des
libertés individuelles et nous suivons
la situation ici merci beaucoup aux gets
a fait ni pour toutes ces précisions en
direct depuis devant le sénat et coûter
à présent l'analyse de notre
éditorialiste alexis poulain concernant
l'extension se passe sanitaire la
république la france c'est un pays il y
à une démocratie on doit débattre avec
les représentants de la nation les élus
et on ne peut pas gouverner par décret
imposé comme ça un changement de vie à
des millions de français au coeur de
l'été d'une semaine sur l'autre en
jouant avec leurs nerfs enjoint aussi
avec leur liberté ce qui se passe
actuellement avec ce pass annie terre
c'est un débat profond qui doit être
sûre à la fois la réelle utilité de se
passe puisque aujourd'hui on voit bien
que les contrôles seraient extrêmement
délicate difficile que la contamination
continuent que la vaccination certes
limites mais n'empêche pas la
propagation du virus
on est en plein délire législatif une
sorte de surabondance pour une oie
ubuesque difficile à appliquer encore
une fois au la porte est d'ailleurs
critiquable donc évidemment emmanuel
macron découvre qu'il ya un parlement et
qu'il faut parler et débattre parce que
nous sommes en démocratie ce ne lui en
déplaise
la situation sanitaire inquiète en
martinique département français le plus
touché par l'épidémie
l'état d'urgence a été rétablie malgré
ça les soignants sont descendus dans la
rue pour manifester
plusieurs centaines de personnes se sont
réunies dans les rues de fort de france
pour protester contre l'obligation
vaccinale les en place par le
gouvernement verra
personnels de santé les manifestants
réclament plus de transparence et une
stratégie différente pour convaincre la
population
nous avons des professeurs émérites nous
avons déversé des praticiens eux mêmes
qui sont divisés sur la question de la
vaccination
comment voulez vous que nous au milieu
nous le commun des mortels que cette
fonction prendre une décision radicale
tranché donc aujourd'hui il faut
convaincre il faut nous apporter la
véracité que cet axe est effective et
efficace
nous sommes ni pour ni contre chacun a
son avis par rapport à la vaccination
seulement nous disons est ce qu'il y a
que cette méthode pour convaincre la
population donc la boucle l'autre
gouvernement n'a pas su convaincre
alors il a créé la contrainte et la
menace évidemment nous sommes contre
cette affaire réponse cinglante de la
chine à l'om est-ce l'organisation
mondiale de la santé avait demandé la
semaine dernière la poursuite de l'
enquête sur les origines du coc vide 19
et notamment un audit des laboratoires
chinois dans la région où est apparu le
virus fin 2019 mais pékin a décidé de
rejeter à sa proposition une attitude
jugée irresponsable et dangereuse pour
un washington écouté le vice-ministre
chinois de la santé
chaud chaud voire d'un pour être honnête
quand j'ai d'abord vu la proposition de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
d'une deuxième étape de l' enquête sur
l'origine du coville 19
j'ai été extrêmement surpris ce plan
retient l'hypothèse d'une violation par
la chine des procédures de laboratoire à
l'origine de la fuite de virus comme l
une des priorités de recherche à partir
de ça je peux sentir le manque de
respect pour le bon sens et une
arrogance envers la science dans ce plan
international en main
emmanuel macron veut des réponses la
sphère et gazeuse continuent de secouer
le monde le chef de l'état réunit ce
matin un conseil de défense
exceptionnelle suite aux possibles
piratages de son téléphone par ce
logiciel israélien via le maroc rabat
attaque forbidden stories et amnesty
international en diffamation et l eso
soutien qui manuel macro ne fait pas
partie de cette liste
à travers l'europe les réactions
s'enchaînent angela merkel demande plus
de restrictions sur la vente de
logiciels espions le parlement israélien
a mis en place une commission d' enquête
sur ces allégations
les précisions et amis la bndes trois
jours de conférences dédiées aux
cyberattaques et quasi aucune allusion à
la sphère pegasus qui secoue pourtant le
monde de la cybersécurité pegasus un
logiciel israélien via lequel le maroc
aurait espionné plusieurs milliers de
personnes parmi elles des journalistes
parlementaires des chefs d'état ou
encore des avocats un outil prisé par
les prédateurs de la liberté de la
presse
ce sont les mots qu'emploie les
journalistes de reporter sans frontières
étonnés du silence d'israël
il réclame aux autorités israéliennes à
moratoire au sujet de l'exportation du
logiciel espion
nous demandons au premier ministre
naftali bennet d'imposer immédiatement
un moratoire sur les exportations de
technologies de surveillance tant qu'un
cadre réglementaire protecteur n'a pas
été établie en réponse naftali bennet
concède la création d'une commission
interministérielle qui comprendra
notamment des diplomates des
représentants du mossad et des
renseignements militaires pour procéder
à une vérification sans pour autant
ouvrir des enquêtes et le ministère
israélien de la défense lui se défend
nous n'approuvons l'exportation de
produits cybernétique qu'au gouvernement
et uniquement pour un usage légal afin
de prévenir le crime et le terrorisme
les pays qui achètent ces systèmes
doivent adhérer aux conditions
d'utilisation de son côté le groupe nso
insiste sur l'indépendance entre le
logiciel et le gouvernement israélien
mso est une entreprise privée il n'est
pas une porte dérobée pour les services
de renseignements israéliens
pourtant l'exportation de ce logiciel
est soumise à l'approbation par l'
agence d exportation de la défense
chaque contrat de haine et ce au passé
avec des clients étrangers reçoit l'aval
des autorités israéliennes
en attendant les relations diplomatiques
entre le maroc et l'état hébreu se
poursuivre comme si de rien n'était les
ministres des affaires étrangères yaïr
lapid a annoncé une rencontre avec le
roi du maroc dès la reprise des vols
directs à la fin du mois de juillet en
guinée en coûte journaliste israélien
est installé à paris cette affaire
d'espionnage est pas sans rappeler la
sphère snowden en 2013
rappelons qu'elle était en 2013 et une
affaire beaucoup plus grave a éclaté et
quand la chancelière merkel est le
président hollande d hier ont été
espionnés et par l'agencé de sécurité
par l agence informatique américaine et
par un essor
c'étaient les naissains
ça
c'est un très grand scandale bien sûr
avec des protestations qui attend les
problèmes que dans l'état actuel des
choses dans le monde et tous ces marchés
là est très réglementée et iphone faut y
penser
et parce qu'il s'agit aussi d'armes il
s'agit pas donc des armes qui tuent
directement mais bien sûr quand on
revend des logiciels et à des
gouvernements afin qu'ils procèdent pour
la sécurité de l'état et contre le
terrorisme il ya des différentes
définitions laisser le terrorisme ce qui
est pour l'heure une époque où l autre
accord trouvé entre washington et berlin
sur le projet nord stream deux objectifs
clore la discorde de ce gazoduc reliant
la russie à l'allemagne selon elle kiev
et varsovie l'accord menacent l'ukraine
et l'europe centrale et je voyais le
néant gala merkel ont convenu de
soutenir l'ukraine et la pologne en en
finançant des projets d'énergie et de
développement alternatif et si la
chancelière allemande se félicite des
accords trouvés
elle n'en n'oublie pas de rappeler tout
le travail qu'il reste à accomplir pour
y aboutir coûteux
c'est une avancée qui a nécessité une
volonté de compromis de la part des deux
parties
de notre côté il me permet pas de
surmonter toutes les divergences qui
existaient encore la veille cela
signifie que je suis satisfait ce que
nous ayons réussi à avancer
cela dit il nous reste bien entendu
toute une série de tâches à accomplir
f notamment pour voir si nous pouvons
obtenir des périodes de traiter plus
longue pour l'ukraine
hors les murs foutraque c'est une fêlure
nounours et face à la méfiance des
dirigeants allemands et américains
moscou a tenu à travers la porte du pape
porte parole du ministère des affaires
étrangères a qualifié sa position
rappelant l qu'elle ne s'était jamais
opposés à un rapprochement stratégique
entre l'ukraine et d'annuler sans ces
clichés sur la soi disant agression
russe halak la chance d auteur nous ne
pouvons que répéter que la russie n'a
jamais utilisé
provisionnés en énergie ou la question
du transit comme arme
il n'a pas l'intention de le faire à
l'avenir il n'y a tout simplement pas
d'exemple au contraire nous avons
toujours prôné la dépolitisation de la
coopération énergétique et son
développement avec tous les pays sur la
base des principes du respect des
intérêts des partenaires et de bénéfice
mutuel
nous ne sommes aucunement hostile à la
création d'un fonds vert pour l'ukraine
sous le contrôle de l'allemagne étaient
si kiev espère que l'occident sera en
mesure de répondre aux besoins de sa
population et de l'économie du pays
grâce à des injections d'argent vers les
énergies renouvelables solaire éolienne
c'est la sphère des dirigeants
ukrainiens et bien sûr du peuple
ukrainien à qui ses dirigeants en
promenade la partie russe ne fera que se
féliciter de la contribution ambitieuse
de l'ukraine à la lutte contre le
changement climatique et à la réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
pour que le blanche faisant expert en
relations internationales le projet
serait positif dans l'ensemble de
l'europe
je pense que c'est favorable d'abord à
l'ensemble de l'union européenne puisque
cela crée des infrastructures fixes
entre la russie et des pays de l'union
européenne en passant par l'allemagne et
que ces infrastructures fixes
fournissent du gaz par conséquent c'est
une garantie d'approvisionnement
je pense aussi que c'est favorable à la
conception d'une grande europe par
ailleurs d'une europe de lisbonne à
vladivostok comme on dit puisque ça
montre la complémentarité qu'il y a
entre les ressources naturelles que l'on
trouve en russie est le plus grand
marché de consommation au monde qui
l'union européenne
un triste anniversaire célébré en
norvège il y a dix ans en der c'est vrai
big tué 77 personnes à oslo et sur l'île
d'utoya schiro rist d'extrême droite
avait soigneusement préparé son plan
pour en finir avec le multiculturalisme
en tour en images sur cette attaque
meurtrière 22 juillet 2011
ander behring breivik 32 ans militant au
sein d'un parti national conservateur
adresse un manifeste à 1002 adresse
email
parmi lesquelles celles de politiciens
et de journalistes norvégiens
le titre de ce livre 2083 une
déclaration d'indépendance européenne
l'homme procède ensuite en deux temps
d'abord en plein centre d'oslo la
capitale
à 15h26 à proximité du bureau du premier
ministre
il fait exploser une voiture piégée huit
personnes sont tuées
deux heures plus tard grimés en
policiers et transportant un arsenal en
dirt brevik fait irruption sur l'île
d'utoya où se tient le rassemblement
annuel de la ligue des jeunes
travaillistes norvégiens
il s'engage dans une chasse à l'homme et
à basse 69 personnes pour la plupart
âgés de 14 à 18 ans
à 18h34 il se livre à des policiers 16
avril 2012 début du procès entré au
tribunal d'oslo dont anders breivik
saluant le poing fermé geste qu'il
reproduit ensuite des années durant sous
l'oeil des caméras
la question posée alors est de savoir si
breivik est sain d'esprit et donc
responsable ou non de ses actes il
explique avoir voulu en finir avec le
multiculturalisme et affirme son soutien
à l'islamophobie au populisme et au
nationalisme blanc 24 août 2012
après plusieurs expertises sanders
brevik est jugé responsable de ses
agissements et condamnés pour actes
terroristes
il écope de 21 ans de prison la peine
maximale en norvège qu'il purge
actuellement
malgré une tentative d'appel
la cheffe du gouvernement norvégien et
un à solberg a rendu hommage aux
victimes aujourd'hui elle affirme
vouloir s'attaquer plus que jamais au
frigo de len lye mois nous devons pas
laisser la haine sans opposition la
terreur nous a montré qu'il était
nécessaire de renforcer la préparation
de la norvège nous y avons travaillé
systématiquement au cours des dix
dernières années qui se sont écoulées
nous avons satisfait à toutes les
recommandations de la commission du 22
juillet la capacité de la norvège à
faire face au terrorisme et au crime
grave est plus forte que jamais en
afrique du sud le bilan s'alourdit selon
les derniers chiffres les émeutes et
pillages ont fait 337 morts et le coût
des violences est estimé à 3 4 milliards
de dollars
les émeutes ont éclaté le 9 juillet
dernier au lendemain de l'incarcération
de l'ex président sud africain jacob
zuma pour outrage à la justice à 12
anouma fils de l'ancien président a
publié une vidéo controversée sur son
compte instagram appelant les
sud-africains à plier jeu le site de
manière responsable et depuis il a réagi
au micro de nos confrères de rtl
internationale on écoute ce qui se passe
est inacceptable je parle du niveau des
ravages et de destruction du vandalisme
à l'égard de la propriété les pillages
volontaire ne devrait pas être célébré
ils doivent être condamnés ce que j'ai
fait et je vais continuer à le faire
malheureusement c'est ce qui se passe on
a dit que j'étais un des instigateurs
pas d'une manière officielle
ils ont fait tout un cirque autour des
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux et
certaines chaînes d'info qui sont très
loin de la vérité
si on considère les fondements de ces
accusations elles sont complètement non
fondées
j'ai dit ok nous avons certains clips
vidéo contenant ma voix et mon image qui
sont réels ils sont tirés du contexte
par rapport à cette vidéo et au message
que je voulais transmettre tentative de
coup d'état et d'assassinats contre le
président des jouets à madagascar à six
personnes dont deux français ont été
interpellés selon les informations de la
procureure générale malgache il
prévoyait de neutraliser plusieurs
personnalités politiques non le chef
d'état andry rajoelina s est la deuxième
fois de l'année que le président ben ali
a échappé à une tentative d'assassinât
un nouveau défi sécuritaire à assumer
pour le gouvernement qui s'ajoutent aux
enjeux sociaux et sanitaires denis six
personnes ont été arrêtées dans le cadre
de cette affaire dont un étranger de
binationaux et trois malgaches
la police avait des renseignements sur
cette affaire depuis plusieurs mois des
armes et de l'argent ont été saisis lors
de ces interpellations qui ont eu lieu
au même moment mais dans des endroits
différents
il ya aussi des documents officiels qui
prouvent leur implication nouveau
naufrage en méditerranée hier 366
personnes âgées de 15 à 48 ans ont été
secourus par les marées une tunisienne
et libyenne est 17 personnes ont trouvé
la mort selon les autorités tunisiennes
une enquête a été ouverte pour connaître
les circonstances exactes du naufrage
les précisions de notre correspondant au
maghreb bassam chebbi un nouveau
sauvetage en mer pour la marine
tunisienne qui assiste impuissante à l'
exode de populations venues d'asie et
d'afrique subsaharienne contrainte de
passer par les côtes tunisiennes et
libyennes pour rejoindre l'europe
mercredi près de trois cent soixante six
migrants ont été secourus au large des
côtes tunisiennes
dix sept personnes y ont laissé la vie
selon le chef du croissant-rouge dans le
gouvernorat de médenine ses 366 migrants
étaient principalement originaires du
bangladesh du maroc ou encore de
l'egypte selon nos informations ces
migrants sont décédés des suites de
suffocation dus à la fumée du moteur du
bateau après un problème survenu en
pleine mer pour le directeur exécutif du
forum tunisien des droits économiques et
sociaux tant que des solutions ne seront
pas trouvé entre l'union européenne et
les pays du sud
des tentatives de migration illégale
continueront de prendre de l'ampleur
on va compter
toujours le nombre des disparus on va
compter toujours le nombre des morts
dans le bassin permien parce qu'il n'ya
pas des approches de qui cherchent une
solution durable ni sur le plan
législatif vous faut pas oublier les
thalys jusqu'aujourd'hui elle
criminalise le sauvetage en mer
l'union européenne finance les la garde
maritime tunisienne ou bien européenne
aussi avec le système de frontex pour
lutter contre l'immigration
l'objectif s'il était contré migration
et non pas sauver des êtres humains
je crois que le message est clair le la
lutte au togo mais contre cette
migration ne passe jamais par la
solution sécuritaire faut des solutions
durables et sur des solutions dignes et
des solutions qui respectent les droits
humains
je crois que c'est important de se
relancer dans un dialogue
mais d'etarras mien depuis le début de
l'année la tunisie a secouru et
accueilli plus d'un millier de migrants
parti de libye dont les embarcations
avait fait naufrage ce sont pas moins de
onze mille départs par la mer depuis la
libye soit 73 % de plus qu'à la même
période l'an passé en raison notamment
des crises politiques économiques et
sociales dans la région retour en france
c'est une action historique qu'ont
décidé de mener 6 associations pour
faire cesser les contrôles au faciès
après avoir mis en demeure le
gouvernement en janvier dernier pour
demander des mesures concrètes les
associations seront passées ce jeudi à
la deuxième étape en déposant leur
requête devant le conseil d'état une
première en france
un rapport du défenseur des droits avait
conclu en 2010 est qu'un jeune perçu
comme noirs ou arabes avaient une
probabilité 20 fois plus élevé de se
faire contrôler une conférence de presse
a été donnée aujourd'hui écoutés en
france en fait il n'y a eu aucune action
qui a été prise malgré le fait que ces
pratiques sont documentés connus
reconnus dénoncé le président de la
république a reconnu l'existence de
contrôles discriminatoires en décembre
2020 mais le gouvernement a toujours
failli à son obligation d'agir pour
faire disparaître ce grave manquement
c'est une procédure qui est historique
où on s'appuie sur un texte de loi qui
est assez robuste et qui permet au juge
administratif d'ordonner à l'état
l'ensemble de mesures nécessaires pour
faire disparaître ces discriminations
qui n'a que trop duré et donc on a
d'énormes espoirs dans cette dans cette
nouvelle considérant même pour embêter
certains jeunes bien connu on les
contrôle quatre cinq six fois dans dans
la journée bon et donc il faut apprendre
que la police elle n'est pas seulement
aux services de l'état
la police elle est au service de la
population voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à tous de l'avoir suivi
prochain point sur l'actualité dans une
trentaine de minutes
en attendant reste égal avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer cinq ans de psychodrame
50 négociations politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre vab
ap